estos problemas de ángulos me están
gustando bastante vamos con el problema
número 46 dice en la siguiente figura ab
el segmento ave es paralelo al segmento
c de esta de acá es paralela esta de acá
va lo marcamos y además nos dan una
cierta unas ciertas medidas de estos
ángulos nos preguntan cuál es el valor
de x muy bien entonces teniendo estas
paralelas podemos pensar de como una
transversal déjame ver si lo puedo
marcar y que quede más o menos bonito
esta es una recta esta es otra recta y
podemos pensar aa de como una
transversal como una transversal
entonces a partir de esto podemos pasar
estos ángulos de la siguiente manera si
este es x + 40 entonces este de acá es
el correspondiente y por lo tanto
también mide x más 40 grados lo escriben
un poco chistoso pero bueno x más 40
entre paréntesis grados pero eso sirve
para observar que ahora x 40 x 40 son
medidas de ángulos suplementarios y por
lo tanto sus sumes en 180 grados vamos a
ver qué ecuación nos da
quedaría que x 40 más x más 40 más 40 es
igual a 180 grados porque son
suplementarios forman esta línea
entonces 2x este se cancela con este es
igual a 180 grados y dividiendo entre 2
ambos lados nos queda que x es igual a
90 a 90 vale bueno creo que aquí ya no
es grados por lo de los paréntesis raros
pero bueno x es igual a 90 a 90 y eso es
la opción de muy bien vamos al problema
número 47 el problema número 47 voy a
voy a centrarlo un poco más dice las
medidas de los ángulos internos o
internos de un pentágono son 2 x 6 x 4 x
6 2 x menos 16 y 6 x más 2 cuál es la
medida en grados del ángulo más grande
bueno pues sería bueno recordar cuál es
la suma de los ángulos internos de un
pentágono y bueno aunque haya una
fórmula para para un polígono en general
siempre es bueno saber de dónde sale
siempre podemos dividir
al polígono en triángulos igual hay una
fórmula para el número de triángulos
pero es mucho más intuitivo y bueno va a
ayudar más en el futuro cuando a uno se
le olvidan las cosas recordar pues cuál
es la intuición detrás vale también lo
malo de la fórmula es que pues puede que
las recuerdes pero no tengas mucha
confianza en usarla o que la recuerda
espero que la recuerdes mal eso sería
pésimo verdad
entonces para no confiar totalmente en
la memoria mejor vamos a usar nuestra
intuición entonces si tenemos cualquier
pentágono lo podemos dividir en tres
triángulos entonces la suma de los
ángulos internos del pentágono es sumar
todos los ángulos de estos triángulos
son los que estoy marcando cada uno de
estos triángulos coopera con 180 grados
180 grados y entonces la suma de los
ángulos internos de este pentágono o
allá de cualquier pentágono estrés por
180 grados 3 por 180 grados y eso es
igual a 540 grados bueno ahora lo que
nos dan son las medidas de todos los
ángulos internos entonces al sumar todas
estas cantidades nos tiene que dar 540
déjame enlistar las por acá pero
verticalmente para que sea fácil sumar
las 2 x 6 x 4 x menos 64 x menos 62 x
menos 16 2 x menos 10
6 y 6 x 2 6 x + 2 vamos a ver cuánto nos
da la suma 2 y 6 son 8 y 4 12 12 y 2 14
y 6 20 aquí tenemos 20 x ahora vamos con
los números menos 6 menos 16 es menos 22
- 22 12 es 20 es menos 20 entonces nos
queda 20 x menos 20 si lo hice bien
menos 22 2 menos 20 si entonces 20 x 20
debe ser igual a 540 a 540 pasamos el 20
sumando sumamos 20 de ambos lados nos
queda 20 x es igual a 560 y dividiendo
entre 20 nos queda que haber entre 10
éste se cancela con este y entre 2 x nos
queda igual a 28
a 28 pero ojo nos preguntan la medida
del ángulo más grande no hay que
dejarnos engañar por este 28 entonces
todavía tenemos que ver cuál de éstos es
el más grande pero claramente este
verdad es 6 x más otra cosa que le gana
a todos los demás entonces la medida del
más grande es multiplicar 28 por 6 6 por
8 48 llevamos 4 6 por 2 12 y 4 que
llevamos 16 es 3 168 y hay que sumar 2
hay que sumar 2 entonces nos queda igual
a 170 entonces la medida en grados es ce
170 muy bien pasemos ahora al problema
número 48
nos preguntan cuánto es la medida del
ángulo 1 de este ángulo 1 de acá esto se
ve divertido hay dos formas de resolver
esto podríamos jugar el juego de los
ángulos para ir encontrando muchos
ángulos por ejemplo este es 36 aquí está
el complemento que es 90 menos 36 luego
aquí adentro bueno este es 88 aquí está
el suplemento de 88 y luego podemos
utilizar la forma de los ángulos
internos de un triángulo es una forma
pero vamos a utilizar el truco que
acabamos de ver de los ángulos externos
observa que este ángulo de acá eso sí lo
vamos a hacer es el complemento de 36 o
sea es 90 menos 36 son los 90 grados
menos 36 grados y esto de aquí es igual
a 54 grados
54 grados pero ahora 88 es ángulo
exterior en este triángulo de aquí en
este triángulo de aquí vale entonces el
ángulo 1 con 54 grados el ángulo 1 con
54 grados debe ser igual a 88 grados
otra vez porque este de acá es ángulo
externo
entonces el ángulo 1 es igual a 88 menos
54 y 34 grados muy bien entonces la
respuesta sería a el ángulo 1 el ángulo
1 tiene medida 34 grados muy bien vamos
a bajar el problema número 49 lo voy a
hacer en color naranja
dice cuánto es la medida del ángulo w zx
v w x este de acá
bueno tenemos medidas más bien como de
este lado entonces nos convendría este
ángulo pasarlo para que utilizando que
es opuesto por el vértice z a este de
este lado entonces encontrar este es lo
mismo que encontrar este de acá vale y
observa una vez más aquí afuera tenemos
un ángulo un ángulo externo entonces 52
grados más x 52 grados más x es igual a
132 grados
132 grados entonces restando 52 de ambos
lados tenemos que x es igual a 80 grados
entonces estoy aquí es 80 grados la
respuesta es y otra vez pudimos haberlo
hecho de una forma un poquito más larga
que igual tampoco es tan complicada pero
bueno pudimos haber encontrado el
suplemento 132 para 180 es igual a 48
grados 48 y pudimos haber visto que aquí
necesitábamos 80 grados para que sumar a
180 vale bueno estas son dos formas de
resolver este problema de aquí y
finalmente vamos a pasar al problema 50
el problema 50 dice cuál es la medida de
un ángulo exterior de un hexágono
regular va entonces con hexágono regular
se refiere a que todos los lados y todos
los ángulos miren lo mismo entonces el
plan va a ser determinar cuál es la suma
de los ángulos internos de un hexágono
regular dividir eso en 36 un hexágono
tiene seis ángulos y eso nos va a dar
cuál es la medida de cada ángulo
interno del hexágono y después de eso
podemos encontrar el ángulo exterior o
el ángulo externo entonces vamos a hacer
eso déjame dibujar aquí un hexágono
arbitrario
este de aquí es cualquier hexágono que
nosotros querramos 1 2 3 4 5 6 y
entonces pues misma idea como lo hacemos
para encontrar la suma de los ángulos
internos pues lo dividimos en triángulos
cuántos triángulos nos quedan pues vamos
a ver dibujamos estas diagonales
nos quedan 123 cuatro triángulos
entonces la suma de los ángulos internos
es 4 por ciento ochenta grados y eso es
igual a por 12 360 por otros dos son 720
grados vale bueno esta es la suma de los
ángulos internos pero en un hexágono
regular todos estos ángulos miden lo
mismo y son 6 entonces cada uno de ellos
mide 720 700 s
pero parece 6 720 grados entre 6 y 72
entre 6 es 12 pero tenemos este cero
entonces nos quedaría 120 grados
entonces ojo los ángulos internos de un
hexágono regular los internos cada uno
mide 120 grados pero nos preguntan la
medida del ángulo x
de cada ángulo exterior entonces lo que
tendríamos que hacer es encontrar el el
suplemento verdad el ángulo
suplementario a 120 grados 180 menos 120
60 grados y por lo tanto la respuesta es
de 60 grados muy bien déjame echarle un
ojo a este problema
para ver si lo hacemos ahorita
demostración de pitágoras no sabes que
como es una demostración mejor los
dejamos para el próximo vídeo y les
dejamos hasta ahorita aquí en el 50 nos
vemos hasta la próxima